Debra I'm gonna start at the end there
is a credit the final credit we see
about this film inspired by Patrick
Perkins can you tell us who that person
is and how he inspired this film yeah I
was volunteering in a local public
school my mother had passed away I was
looking for something meaningful to do
and to give back and I met Patrick when
he was six years old he was a very
bright cheerful positive person already
showing signs of leadership when he was
six and as I was getting ready to go
back to work and I was walking out the
door I asked the assistant teacher what
Patrick's story was and she told me he
had been removed from his parents and he
was living in an orphanage called Holly
Grove which happens to be an orphanage
where Marilyn Monroe spent some time and
I had never encountered a foster youth
or the foster care system and I went
home sobbing and resolved to continue to
work with him and I never left it's been
25 years he just turned 31 and I view
him like him my son and he views me like
his mother Deborah the system has its
strengths and it has its weaknesses but
something that the system also has is a
respect for the privacy of the children
who are in the foster care system and
that as a filmmaker would present I
suspect some issues in terms of access
so how do you work within the system to
make sure that you have the trust of the
system and that then you can identify
the people that you want to follow
because I suspect it doesn't take a
couple of days maybe a couple of months
maybe more than that yeah we're very
lucky that the presiding judge of the
Los Angeles County System believed in a
transparent Court and he would always
try to invite people in and and they
wouldn't come primarily journalists but
other people as well so that was the
first step we CC 35 people on every
media request to the court to have
permission to film a child with an open
case and then we worked very closely
with children's Law Center the law firm
who represents all the children in the
system to make sure the
see rights of the children were honored
and respected but also that the children
understood what they were getting
themselves into particularly I mean
obviously for crystalline she's a
newborn child but in the case of Sydney
and danisha they took a vote and we met
mrs. beavers two years before we started
filming and they put a vote to the
family and Sydney didn't and Anisha
voted to be in the film so it was very
important to everybody that that they
understand that this material will live
on Deborah is very hard to say no to
that's that's part of the way we got
access that she kept showing that we
kept showing up and saying that we
wanted to make an accurate film and we
were not there to try to do an expose
about the Department of Children and
Family Services we really wanted to
understand the welfare system and I
think people after Patong believed us
and and one of the aspects of that is
that when Mark and I were first talking
about doing in the subject that we felt
that the way the subject is ordinarily
depicted is at the time of a crisis that
the public gets their information when
there's a fatality and something that we
we can all agree is horrific and really
disturbing and that very often the press
or investigative journalists and we
wanted to come from a different point of
view because we felt that when the
public gets their information that the
in that way they turn away and despair
and we wanted to turn that despair into
engagement if at all possible what were
you looking for what were the challenges
in shooting this film what we were
looking for we were looking somebody who
was really good but when we first met
Nick you and we're talking about because
this was very much an observational film
correct and
and were intervening in very dramatic
moments we thought in in very intimate
settings and I had and we were asked
Nick how he did that and Nick said well
I just kind of curl up in a ball and
tried to disappear
he said he puts on a cloak of
invisibility and then he he he squatted
down really to show and he actually did
appear to disappear and the other great
thing about Nick was that we filmed for
90 days and Nick made a commitment and
and stuck with it which is a really big
deal that there's not a different person
coming in to operate and I'm gonna
outside the cloak of invisibility that
you borrowed from Harry Potter what does
that mean in terms of how you shoot what
kind of crew you bring how you blight it
how small can you be and how quickly do
you realize that you have become
invisible to the subjects I think I
learned a valuable lesson one time we
were I was shooting a scene in a hotel
room and it was these people from Comic
Con we were counting up their money and
they were all celebrating because they
had $50,000 and they put them in piles
of thousands and they were like pointed
after 25 and then they counted again and
Kennedy knew this was 350 but there was
only 25 and you could see is like 25
grand missing and the atmosphere in the
room could be changed the producer left
the room went to the bathroom the guy
with the boom pole looked away and I
just corrected hoping they wouldn't see
me
and then they continued with the scene
and then I realized they were accusing
the people behind me they were literally
just touching so then I had to stand up
and turn around and get a shot then I
went back down again and no one said
stop so I was like okay and that's my
method man and part of it is just hiding
behind the camera I just hide your face
but you can see there's a great moment
in the film I think that really a test
and Nick's skill is when the baby has a
seizure and Nick just holds still and
even don't hold still I think I learned
that one just like
like don't do anything just oh it looks
like that baby is not moving it's bad
and then hold still
and it's because then all the people
move into the frame from outside and so
it's like a single basically a single
take cut up a little bit but mark and I
weren't in the room the room was so
small and in order for Nick to get it
all around the room we left because
you'd be in the shot yes so yeah and so
we were on headsets outside the door and
all of a sudden you heard what was going
on the wind it went very silent it went
very silent and everyone just looked at
the baby and I mean you guys were
outside but you knew something serious
was going on because the conversation
just ended and I mean that thing I just
completely stood still and at one point
if you look in that shot there's the
babies the bottles kind of in front his
face and I needed to be two inches
higher but to go two inches higher I
would have to do one of those yoga pose
and I was like I'm not gonna hold that
for very long so I just held it still
again because if I move and draw
attention to myself
it changes the scene and people might
say okay you need to stop filming this
because there's no baby looks in a bad
way okay at what point do you start
figuring out and in consultation with
your with director and your producer
about what are the stories the people
are gonna focus on and how you come up
with a narrative where you feel that you
can stay with somebody for a certain
period of time and come back to somebody
how do you start an assembly on a movie
like this because it seems monumental
yes it was well fortunately when you
have such incredible people to work with
who are so compassionate and kind and
create a space where people open up and
and there's trust they're the kind of
material that we got that was it was
incredible you know it was just so so
powerful so one of the challenges is
bringing it down but I had a - an
assistant Bert Cornish and
another AE youngbleaux long who really
helped to bring the material down so
they would give me long long select
scenes and you kind of just go scene by
scene character by character and putting
each character story together and then
looking for the intersections or the
ways that one story informs another
because I see a film like this with
multiple people in it as like a relay
race someone starts and then it's handed
off to the next person and so forth and
so it's finding those connecting links
and bringing it through and I also
always think in terms of a three-act
structure if you think about how this
film and I mean this truly how its cast
the kinds of stories that you want to
tell within the limitations that you're
facing when you think about Jessica's
story rayon and Chris's story Mary story
Dasani story the mother of the year mrs.
beavers what are you looking for and how
do you figure out why this is a good mix
we made a decision to film entirely in
Los Angeles County for a number of
reasons one because we were all here and
if the stories were taking place across
the country we would not have been able
to capture something like Chris land
seizure or some of the other incidents
in the film so there were economic
interests and also access interests but
we never wanted this movie - we never
wanted to suggest that this movie was
about la we wanted our type of stories
that could take place anywhere across
the country so christen was meant to
represent the earliest point at which a
child can enter the system so that was a
newborn baby with the positive
toxicology and we got phone calls every
day for three months from the hotline
letting us know that another child had
been born with drugs in their system and
if a story wasn't going to work out or
wasn't quite right very sadly we knew
that there would be another phone call
within a very short period of time we
also wanted to show the other end of the
spectrum which was the youth aging out
of the system because not all states
have extended care to 21 and for every
year that a child gets to stay within
the system beyond 18 years of age it
reduces the incidence of homelessness
drug addiction pregnancy early death
really serious consequences and outcomes
for these children Dasani story was put
on our radar by the hilton Foundation
and Barbra Dewey says that line in the
movie about in an intact family if
children acted out that they would
suffer consequences and be punished but
they wouldn't face charges and then we
felt a responsibility to show a good
foster parent we were going down a path
with another woman and we mentioned that
to the Department of Children and Family
Services and they said you think she's
great you should meet mrs. beavers they
were very happy to meet mrs. beavers and
then the final story was Jessica
Chandler who just had experienced so
many different aspects of the system a
probation youth the pregnant teen of
foster youth who wanted to blow up the
entire system and instead represents the
importance of one consistent caring
adult who never gave up on her never
judged her and she as she says she went
from testing at the third grade math
level when she graduated high school to
getting her master's in social work and
now working from within to reform the
system you know those are the kinds of
stories were looking for but in the end
casting is key and for me the best
characters for documentary and for
fictional films as well are people who
are struggling right and we look for
people who want it to be in the film
because being in the film in some ways
help to make sense of their own life how
help to in in some ways it's it's
therapeutic Liz having sympathetic
filmmakers validate their lives and
validate the importance of what they're
going through I think is valuable and
then you find people you know them when
you see them when you meet Jessica you
know that she's a person that so
charismatic so honest close to her
feelings and all the people that we met
in the film were articulate and they
were willing to be open about their
lives and they were and they were
willing to trust us and that those are
the most important things I want to
thank Nick Kate
Deborah and Mark for sharing your time
and bringing us your film